ما هي حكايه رشوه اسطوره تشيلسي للبرتغالي
مورينيو عقده نهائي اسيا 2017 تضع دياز
ودوسري في مرمى النيران البرازيلي
رونالدينيو يستعد لاطلاق دوري عالمي للاعب
الشوارع وبعد وصفها بذبابه الميته كيف ردت
صديقه بيكي على شاكيرا هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم عبر قناه العربيه رياضه اسعدوا
بمتابعتكم
احدث تعادل الهلال السعودي مع نظيره اورا
والياباني بهدف لمثله في ذهاب نهائي دوري
ابطال اسيا جدلا كبيرا على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي هذا اللقاء استحوذ على اهتمامات
تويتر خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه وبعدد
يصل لاكثر من 250 الف تغريده حتى اللحظه
المباراه حصدت اهتمام اكثر من 600 الف
تغريده خلال سير المباراه ونحو 65 الف
تغريده تنتقد سالم الدوسري الجدل تواصل
على السوشيال ميديا حتى بعد انتهاء اللقاء
بتحميل الكثيرين المدرب راموندياز مسؤوليه
التعادل وان النتيجه تنذر بتكرار سيناريو
نهائي 2017
في انجلترا كشفت جوكول لاعب تشيلسي
الانجليزي السابق عن محاولته رشوه المدرب
البرتغالي جوزي مورينيو ففي عام 2006 قام
بول بشراء سياره فيراري خاصه وقتها اظهر
مدربه انذاكس برشلونه اعجابه بها وعرض
عليه شرائها وهو امر استغله لاعب البلوزه
السابق ووافق على الصفقه مقابل تجديد عقده
مع تشيلسي وبحسب صحيفه
الامر الى مغادره قلعه ستانفورد نهايه
الموسم
نتحول الى البرازيلي رونالدينيو حيث يعتزم
اطلاق دوريا عالمي لكره القدم في الشوارع
عبر السوشيال ميديا ومن المقرر ان يبدا
الدوري اواخر نهايه هذا العام وسيتضمن في
البدايه اختبارا مهاريا رياضيا يتم نشره
عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي بتحميل مقاطع
مصوره تظهر مهارات اللاعبين في محاوله
للانضمام الى احد الفرق المشاركه للمنافسه
على لقب رونالدينيو كلوب
والان مع الحرب النسائيه الخفيه الدائره
بين الكولومبيه شاكيرا والده ابناء بيكيه
لاعبي برشلونه الاسباني السابق وصديقته
الجديده كلاراشيا التقارير الصحفيه تشير
الى ان ابنه الثالثه والعشرين عاما قد
استفزها لقب الذباب الميته الذي اطلقته
عليها شاكيرا لتقوم بحمله مضاده على
المغني الكولومبيه وتلقبها بالساحره
والعجوز الشمطاء وعلى ذمه المنشور فان
كلارا تخضع حاليا لعلاج النفسي بعدما
تحولت بين ليله وضحاها الى قضيه راي عام
فقدت على اثره هدوء حياتها البعيده عن
الاعلام
الختام مع اليخاندرو قرناتشو واحتفاليه
تمديد عقده مع فريقه مانشستر يونايتد
الانجليزي حتى عام 2022 اللاعب الارجنتيني
الشاب قام بحجز مطعم كامل لعائلته مباشره
بعد توقيه العقد حيث شوهد اليخاندرو مع
صديقته ايفا غارسيا وهما يدخلان المطعم
الساعه الثامنه مساء يوم توقيع العقد